[Music]
exactly 10 years ago today a low
pressure system in the Caribbean grew
into a tropical storm and was given a
name Sandy it would go on to become the
largest Atlantic hurricane on record
with storm force winds extending for
more than a thousand miles and it would
do catastrophic damage including here in
the New York metro area
visited one place where they remember
the storm and are trying to prepare for
the next one Tanya good morning good
morning everyone Staten Island one of
New York City's five boroughs was one of
the places hardest hit by Sandy now an
Innovative project run by the New York
governor's office of storm recovery and
slated to be completed in 2024 is
offering a natural solution to storm
protection by giving a small But Mighty
creature a very big role
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
off this Brooklyn dock a short ferry
ride from Lower Manhattan thousands of
oysters with a big future are quietly
growing we did it
this is what we love
is seeing them grow out Katie Mosher is
senior director at the billion oyster
project a non-profit that has restored a
hundred million oysters and counting all
around New York Harbor they're now about
two inches and they're reproductive so
that means that they can reproduce
larvae that will spread out throughout
the harbor but some of these oysters go
over to the living breakwaters correct
yeah so in about two years we should be
ready to put oysters on the breakwaters
and they'll be on rock materials
positioned in a way so that you have
lots of spaces for all kinds of species
and so oysters will be a part of that
the living breakwaters currently under
construction off Staten Island's
Southern Shore are a series of stone
walls extending 2400 linear feet that
will eventually be covered with tens of
millions of oysters the living part of
the breakwaters a collaborative project
aiming to protect the shoreline and
promote marine life my colleagues and my
teammates we tend to go out once a month
twice a month when we can we rode along
with one of the Project's designers Brad
Howe of design firm scape to see the 107
million dollar work in progress
they've been designed to kind of be
these interlocking woven structures of
rocks and as the waves approach from
this direction they crash into these
structures before they crash into the
shoreline and structures on the
shoreline and do the oysters also help
with the mitigation of the Waves so the
oysters will play a part in it so
eventually the the oysters will kind of
settle on this rock structure typically
oyster larvae just kind of float
throughout the harbor and in this area
they don't really have anything to land
on and grow the idea is that the living
breakwaters provide that and then that
oyster growth will just make them more
robust structures that are living
Rosemary what did this area look like
right after Sandy this stock here lifted
and made their way into the window
Rosemary saladino runs the family-owned
Marina Cafe at Staten Island staple for
over 40 years but 10 years ago surging
flood waters from superstorm Sandy
swelling up to 10 feet high decimated
the Harborside Restaurant the water
surged in enough to push the all the
furniture these boats here most of them
all got pushed to the street her
family's life work transformed into a
pile of rubble we prepared for a
hurricane sandbags covering the windows
moving furniture but the devastation was
something that we never imagined that
would have happened saladino rebuilt
with the phoenix-like resilience New
Yorkers are famous for what's up but
she's grateful the government has
projects in place to help weather the
next big storm better than the last how
does it make you feel that they are
building something that is focused on
Staten Island no I think that's that's
awesome and since we were small islands
and sometimes we get forgotten but I
think that's a great thing that we're
not getting forgotten on that
is what makes them unique a Breakwater
itself is not necessarily a new piece of
infrastructure but what makes the living
breakwaters unique is that they've been
designed with kind of structural
modifications that help promote habitat
designed for juvenile fish to find
refuge in the structures they've been
designed for oyster Restoration in the
future designed to not only protect
Staten Island from the next superstorm
but to also offer a new model for
fighting climate change that gives
nature a starring role there we go
the living breakwaters are the result of
a national competition launched after
Sandy challenging landscape designers
Architects urban planners to come up
with new solutions to storm protection
and many believe it is through this kind
of creative collaboration that we will
continue to imagine new solutions for
the next big superstorm it's a win-win
right yeah everybody where's the
negative exactly because we know when it
comes to Super Storms it's not if but
when yeah hard to believe it's been 10
years I know I know we were all covering
it right it was incredible so nice to
see something come out of something so
tragic and devastating yeah thanks Tanya
we appreciate it